- Hello, hello, hello.
Can you hear me?
Yeah, good, okay,
let's go.
- Yeah.
- Are we live?
Are we live, Dustin?
- We are.
- Good.
- Do you want me to skip the theme song?
- No, go to fucking theme song.
I'm in a bad mood, anyway.
That's why we're 30
minutes late, you know?
- Okay.
- [Gary] Hey, everybody.
♪ Tea with GaryVee ♪
(upbeat music)
♪ Just text your questions
and I'll stress them ♪
♪ 'Cause you're sipping tea ♪
♪ Tea with GaryVee ♪
- Good morning.
It's Tea with GaryVee.
Today is Thursday, April 9th.
I'm in a tricky mood.
A lot of business stuff going on.
I had to push this to 9:15
because I had a business call,
and that went to 9:30,
because the call needed to go to 9:30.
But I'm here, and you guys
are gonna change my mood,
and my mindset,
and I want to give some
shout outs to Chad Hannah,
Christine, Lauren Lindsey.
It's fun, you guys don't get
to see me in the zone often,
because usually I have a transition,
but you know, listen,
when you're navigating a
thousand person company
during a pandemic, there's
a ton of shit going on,
so big shout out to
all my operational CEOs
who are on the front lines,
who are trying to navigate,
and protect jobs, and navigate this storm,
because this is a fucking storm.
So you know,
that's where we're at,
fucking operating, you know.
Entrepreneurship is super
cool when things are great,
and you look happy on fucking Instagram,
but in real life, we're working out here.
And I've been through 9/11,
I've been through the Great Recession,
and this is a tricky one,
because it's global, it's at scale,
and so real stuff,
but I'm up for the fucking challenge,
because I'm a fucking wartime general,
and now I'm ready to fucking go.
Let's go.
Justin, what's good?
- 'Sup, Gary, how you doing?
- I'm doing unbelievable.
For everybody who's watching right now,
you know what, this is why I fucking love
Tea With GaryVee.
I didn't know Silly was
gonna be the first guest.
Silly is one of the great
athletes in our world.
He is a superstar on our Minnesota ROKKR
esports Call of Duty team.
He has been performing our team.
Just has been performing.
We've been stunning them.
We're not stunned,
but in the Call of Duty league this year,
no question, given the history
if you know that league,
we were not perceived to be a team
that is in the upper echelon,
or there was unknowns.
We were not one of the,
kind of, hype teams
going into the season,
but we have made some real fucking noise,
no short part because of this man
and his incredible teammates.
So it's so weird to be an owner of a team,
and have an athlete on
your team, and here it is.
You know, Justin, not exactly
how I pictured it as a kid,
I thought I'd be a football
player, and I'd be old as shit,
but I'm enjoying it
tremendously, I'm proud of you.
And how are you?
How you doing?
How's the family?
- Doing great.
Family's nice and safe.
You know, just practicing from home,
and getting ready for our
tournament this weekend.
- Yeah, we're back on, which is amazing,
and I'm excited about that.
So how's the season been going so far,
before we go into your question?
- The season for us has
been going pretty well.
We've kind of proved to be a
championship contender team,
and you know, that's awesome for us,
because we felt that
way before the season,
and now we're actually
showing it.
- We did.
- My question for you is, you know,
since most traditional sports
are on pause right now,
what are watching more of?
- You know, if you saw the
first couple of minutes
of this episode, I'm not watching shit,
because unfortunately, I've made my bed,
and now I have to sleep in it.
I've got huge responsibility,
I'm working late into
the night, every night,
looking at every angle
to grow our business,
and maintain our business,
and navigate this storm.
We're in a business where
you've got a lot of people
who are struggling to pay their bills,
you've got people that
are reducing their scopes.
I'm just dealing with a ton of shit.
So right now, unfortunately,
not even the news,
not even music, I'm going
at it 15 hours a day,
kind of going hard on, you know...
When you're a captain of a boat,
and the seas get rough,
you know, when it's chill,
and it's front of you,
you can go in the back, and
hang out with the patrons,
and maybe have a glass of champagne.
Right now, I'm hand on
wheel, trying to navigate it.
However, because I'm
always paying attention
through osmosis and doing what I do,
this is really my one release each day,
I'm very aware of what's
going on with Twitch numbers,
and YouTube numbers, and
very aware that our sport
is in a disproportionate
position to succeed.
The other sports, big
shout out to Ronnie 2K.
Like, 2K's doing ESPN, you know?
Like, this is our time,
and I think this weekend,
the viewership is going
to be extraordinary
if we, and our league, and I, and you,
we promote properly, and
let people know it's on.
Actually, on that point, I
want to let everybody know,
because a lot of people
are about to become
Minnesota ROKKR fans,
because they're fans of me,
and they're like, "Fuck it,
I'm gonna watch this weekend."
Where can everybody catch
this weekend's tournament?
- This weekend's tournament
is going to be on
twitch.tv/codleague.
All the match will be broadcasted there,
and we play at 7:00pm east on Friday
against our rivals, the Chicago Huntsmen.
- So this is a big one for
everyone who's watching,
Hector in OG, in the Call
of Duty circles, and I
became friends years ago.
He's a part owner and GM of Chicago.
This is a huge battle.
We talk a lot of trash
on opening weekend in
Minnesota, on social.
I'm super fired up for it,
and I can't wait to
see what you do, Silly.
You've been remarkable, brother.
I continue to, obviously, every week,
get more educated on
the nuances of the game,
and I'm just blown away by your skills,
and I appreciate what you're doing.
- Yeah--
- Silly, Taylor's asking,
"What kinda gameplay?"
Explain the format.
- Like the tournament format?
- Mm-hmm.
With the gameplay,
the games you're playing
within the five...
- Okay, so the games we're playing,
we're strictly Call of Duty
on the Minnesota ROKKR.
We're in an 18 tournament
format this weekend.
There's two separate pools,
and we pretty much just broadcast
our skills in Hardpoint,
Search & Destroy, and Domination.
- There it is.
That's what I was looking for.
That's awesome.
Everybody follow Minnesota ROKKR.
Dustin, get the handle from Team GaryVee,
if it's off the top of your head.
Let's get the Twitter and
Instagram handle up here.
Let's make sure everybody
who's watching right now
becomes a ROKKR fan.
Minnesota, baby.
Justin, thank you.
- Thank you so much,
and thanks for having me on.
- Talk to you soon.
Of course, Silly, take care.
Love that, thank you,
team, for that surprise.
I didn't know he was gonna be on.
Super cool.
I like the little surprises
in the beginning of the shows.
It's been really fun.
Let's keep this going.
Kara!
- Hi.
- Oh, this is going really well.
All right, now I'm in a good mood.
How are you?
By the way, thank you so much for...
Every body who's watching right now,
if you don't know who
this incredible icon is
in media and technology, like,
you're making a huge mistake, A.
B, her podcast is such a beast.
I did it the other day.
I'm excited to hear her perspective on it,
it was the first time we
really got to jam at length,
and my phone exploded.
All my smartest Silicon Valley,
like, everybody I admire,
who I've either talked to often,
or I haven't talked to in three years,
hit me up and just said how
great our chemistry was,
and how quality the show was.
- Yeah, it was great.
You offered a lot of really good insights.
I think people were looking
for super interesting insights
about management, and
how to run a company,
and some of the struggles,
and I think you showed off your struggles,
and I think a lot of people don't do that.
They don't say what they're
worried about, and they don't...
It's not like you're being sensitive,
or anything else, or
you're like a sensitive,
New Age male.
- Transparent.
- But you're like, "Hey,
this is the problem,"
and I think people appreciate
that, because they're
going for it themselves.
- Appreciate it.
How've you been
the last couple weeks?
- Good, real good.
Since we last talked,
all well?
- Good, yeah, yeah.
- Are the podcast
numbers through the roof?
People consuming
content like crazy?
- You know what,
I have to tell you,
mine are up quite a lot.
It's interesting, I changed
my programing around
really quickly in the coronavirus crisis.
- Smart.
- I'm covering economics,
I have health care people on,
I had Esther Perel talking
about relationships,
you know what I mean?
And then I had an economist on,
and so I've changed up the programing,
and so the numbers have
increased rather dramatically.
- This is what happens
when you have skills,
(Kara laughs)
since you are actually
a media professional,
and know what you're doing.
- I know my audience.
I know my audience.
- Yeah, I mean, to your point,
I've been watching some podcasts
stay on the same subject matter,
which is actually tone
deaf during this time.
Good for you.
I mean it, everybody, if you get a chance,
I know a lot of you are watching,
but in your side tab, just Google Kara.
You really should know about her career.
She's somebody really worth admiring.
You have a question, Kara?
- Yes, I do.
You know, my column this week,
I write a column for the
New York Times every week,
and last week I wrote about Sean Hannity,
I mean, about Fox News
and the misinformation.
(Gary laughs)
I don't want to talk about that,
because those people lost
their mind when I pointed out--
- Yes, I'm sure it gets
very emotional, very fast.
Go ahead.
- No, it was unemotional, but in any case,
I wrote about the PPP loans,
and I wondered whether tech
companies should take them,
and so that was the debate.
I know there's a debate going
on among start ups with VCs,
and VCs tend not to want
to take these PPP loans
to protect payroll,
and they're available
for small businesses.
- And Kara, educate me, why would...
Yeah, I'm aware of the PPP loans,
but why in the sub-culture
of venture-backed land,
where you play a lot of,
why are the VCs against it?
- Well, they're against it
because they think they
should take bridge loans,
and that they might have to change
some of the governing
rules of these things,
because there's a thing
called affiliate companies,
where they regroup all
of these companies together.
- Yep, I got it, I got it.
- And so they don't want to do that.
They don't want to reveal
a lot of information that you might,
but some of these companies
don't want to do layoffs, you know?
And if other people think
they're just trying to, you know,
cull the heard of their bad investment...
- Look, this might be a great
chapter in Silicon Valley,
where companies start realizing that VCs
have their own set of responsibilities,
and these are not your buddies,
and your unlimited cash coming to you,
and they are...
I mean, one of my biggest
grudges with VCs, in general,
obviously everyone treats it differently,
is I think that a lot
of people don't realize
that a lot of their behaviors
and advice to companies
is a portfolio statement,
and not a specific for your
company, Susan, or Rick.
And so, to me, when I hear
what you're saying here,
I think I'm hoping that the
start ups get really educated,
that they realize, you're
gonna get advice right now,
from a VC who she or he
is more worried about
what that means for the VC firm
in exposing some of the
dogs, or things like that,
recalibrating, not giving them
leverage to raise a bigger round,
not the fact that they're looking
specifically at your business,
where a PPP is exactly
what you should be doing,
and so I think this is an education time
for a lot of people.
- Well, there's also
the populous argument,
that these are companies that
have availability of capital,
presumably, compared
to a mom and pop store.
Like, most mom and pop stores have
two weeks of cash on hand.
- Yeah, I mean,
I think that's where I probably
skew a little bit more like,
okay, well, they decided
to start a company in tech
during this time, and you
decided to start a laundromat,
and that is some of the things
that come along with it.
Good news, laundromat,
99% of those companies
actually go out of business.
We hear about the ones
that sell to Google,
or Facebook, or go IPO.
We do not hear about, and you know this,
you've been through multiple rodeos,
there's some darlings
right now, 'unicorns',
that are actually not
going to be a business.
- That's absolutely right.
- So I think there's
pros and cons, you know,
and I've been very close
to both my whole life.
There's pros and cons to running
a normal, great business,
that kicks out two
million dollars in cash,
or $200,000 in cash every year.
You have an actual business,
but you're not gonna necessarily
have access to VC money,
because you're not gonna
revolutionize the world,
and get a 500 million dollar
evaluation on an idea...
- And that's reality.
That's the new reality, as you know.
And one of the things that's interesting
is watching Airbnb take
that billion dollars
from Silver Lake and
Sixth Street partners.
You know, they need the money,
and there might have been
terms that were tough on them,
so if they don't have--
- There definitely were.
- Yeah, and if they
don't have the leverage,
and then should because
people are obviously believing
that this will thrive after this is over,
that is you're a small company,
maybe you should consider a
loan to keep people employed.
- Look, my company, every
company, what liquidity,
and for a rainy day just
became super unpopular.
Savings became unpopular.
Everything became offense,
and look, to be frank,
I like these events,
because they do reset,
and you get a little bit
back to some normalcy.
I don't like to say I like them,
because I'm devastated for
people that were hurt by it,
but there is some unbelievable truth
that the people that got hurt
were doing behaviors
that created the hurt.
There's been a lot of people...
Listen, you know a lot about
my story, at least from afar.
I had of leverage to do
a lot of venture raising,
and a lot of certain things,
and I decided to go very practical.
People made decisions,
and those decisions have ramifications.
- Right, absolutely.
It's an interesting time, so you know,
a lot of people have cloud cover
to get rid of stuff they didn't--
- Listen, for all of you that watch me,
I'm a very good communicator,
where I can do something in a snap,
and it can give you a perspective.
Other people are far better at
me of going deep, deep, deep.
This is a podcast you need to listen to.
Kara, what a nice surprise.
Thanks for being on.
- Good luck, bye.
- Take care.
I mean it, a lot of you, I
know the subjects she touches,
and it goes left and
right, and back and forth.
I think a lot of you
could get a lot of value
from listening to her show,
and get a different
perspective, and go deep.
Let's keep it going.
Terrible Johnny, what's good?
- What's good, Gary?
How you feeling?
- I'm hanging in brother, how are you?
- Are you in New York, right now?
- Jersey.
- Jersey, I'm in Brooklyn,
so what you said earlier,
I'm feeling the same exact way.
Wild times.
Absolutely.
- Wild times.
- My question for you, right,
so you're dealing with some
of the things that I'm dealing with.
I have, you would think,
all the time in the world, right now.
You would think, all
the time in the world,
and because I'm stuck at home,
I'm doing my part, staying at home,
and I am a man who does a lot of things.
- Terrible Johnny, excuse me for one sec.
Hey, Dustin, can you drop
the name of the podcast
so people can find it.
Have the team look it up, it's Kara,
it's Recode, it Kara Swisher.
Go ahead, Johnny.
- Yeah, so basically, I'm
just in this new position
where my life has been on
stage and in recording studios,
the two things that
generate income for me,
up until this point.
Now I'm a one man tech team,
we're actually currently on my podcast,
my show, as well, on Twitch,
Talking With Terrible,
at this moment, and I'm making this...
And I'm used to having people around me,
like, an entire team,
that handle things from
fucking walking the dog,
to fucking whatever it
is that I need done.
Doing my laundry, this,
that, and the other.
Now I've got 24 hours of the day,
where my brain is going
a million miles an hour.
How do I compartmentalize the time.
- You don't.
You don't.
You and I are too creative for that shit.
Like, don't beat yourself up.
Like, if the dog takes a shit,
or you don't wash your clothes,
or you missed an opportunity,
or because there aren't people around you,
and you didn't get the energy,
you can't go live for as long.
I mean, I'm nine to 11 on this show,
and I came on at 9:30 today
because I had to take a
business call at nine.
I thought it was 9:15.
Like, you don't beat yourself up.
You just don't over-judge
yourself, Johnny.
Honestly, you don't,
because, you know why?
You're just gonna do the best you can,
and that's awesome.
And some shit's gonna drop,
and other things are not
gonna be an on point,
and then you're gonna
learn some shit about you,
and you're gonna learn new stuff.
I'm telling you bro, don't overthink it,
because we weren't built
for structure, bro.
- Right, that's what the thing is,
is that I'm so used to having
some type of a structure,
and now I'm trying to create my own--
- No, no.
You're used to have
infrastructure around you.
- Perfectly said, yes.
Very much so, and now I'm this
one man team, it feels like.
I mean, I still have access
to other people, right?
I mean, I'm still working with them,
we're able to communicate,
and learning things about myself,
such as use technology
in order to do that,
but it is a completely different
fucking ball game, and--
- Just go with optimism here.
Look, my speaking career
subsidizes my being able
to go all in on everything else.
I've taken a massive hit.
Like, real seven figures,
not one, you know?
Like, million, so like I got
annihilated with speaking.
I only thrive with people around me.
My team is, like, on top of me,
but the reality is, we've
got health, you know, 24...
You know what else, bro?
How old are you?
- Timeless.
I'm timeless, bro.
That's how old I am.
- Fair enough.
- No, tomorrow I'll be 34.
- I love it.
What I like is that now
you have this experience.
- Mm-hmm.
- Now you have this experience.
- Agreed, you know, and it's interesting
because you say you were
here during 9/11, I was not.
I came to Brooklyn in 2010,
and I think to myself,
in a weird and twisted way,
I don't want to make this
sound to sick, but I'm like,
I'm getting to witness part
of history, right here.
- 100...
By the way...
- And I'm like, I take that...
Go ahead.
- No, no, I'm sorry.
Finish your thought, I
know where you're going,
but go ahead.
- Take it as almost a blessing,
in a weird, fucking twisted ass way.
That's like a weird way to put it.
- No, no, no, no, it's not a dark way.
It's actually 100% true,
I think the same thing.
We will be telling the stories of these
three to 12 months for
the rest of our lives.
And you went to Brooklyn 2010, like,
perfect timing, all rocket ship up.
This is good for you, you're a young man.
You're gonna be doing
this for 60 more years.
- Yeah, and you know, I won't
take up too much of your time.
I know that you started late,
and you got a lot of shit to do,
and I really appreciate you
taking the time to speak
with me, because I am obviously
a massive GaryVee fan.
By the way, guys, if you're
on here Talking With Terrible,
and if you don't know who
Gary is, please go check out,
I've got all of his
socials listed right here.
GaryVee on Twitter, YouTube,
and Instagram, check him out.
Fucking (audio cuts out).
- Thank you, brother.
- One last thing.
- Yeah.
- You, me, and Kevin Liles, got
to sit down and have a talk,
because I started a thing with Kev,
and I want to talk to you
about that at a separate point.
- Let's go.
- He gave a shout to me not too long ago
about something in Podcast Land.
I don't know if it's that,
or if it's something else,
but we'll talk.
- It's much bigger, we should talk.
- Love it.
By the way, like, literally hit me up
on DM with him right now,
and let's get this going this
weekend, or early next week.
- I will.
- All right, take care, Johnny.
- Stay well.
Kevin's my guy.
300, incredible label.
All right.
What's good, what's good.
Summer, what's good?
Daniel, what's good?
Jamie Coop.
Great to see you, Pat.
Good, all right, Twitter,
before we get the next one,
take a photo of this, share it.
I'm gonna follow a bunch of you right now.
I'm also asking Brandon for what
the WineText of the day is.
Let's see, all right.
Remi's all ready sharing.
Taylor's all ready sharing.
It is rocking here, ready.
Remi, am I following you?
I have no...
Oh my God, Remi, all these years.
Boom, you got your follow that
you deserved five years ago.
All right, let's go.
Screen shoot, share it on Twitter.
Also, share the URL.
The URL of this livestream with
it, for extra bonus points.
All right, let's keep this going.
Oh, Jared, you know how
to win a boys heart.
- Hey, I'm getting no audio.
- No audio?
All right, work with Dustin.
He's gonna work with you.
He won my heart, and then he went away.
True love taken away from me.
All right, let's keep this going.
I got scared because I
saw the Drock part first,
and I said, "Wait a minute,
we run out of guests?
I got my DRock?"
No, I got a much better looking Drock.
What's good, bro?
- Yeah, what's up, man?
I'm chillin', you know,
I'm in the west coast,
so I had to wake up at six...
- Thank you, thank you.
- So I look very tired.
- No, you look great.
- That's how you know
I'm a big fan.
- Thank you, bro.
- Well, the only question
I really had, Gary, was,
so I've been an Instagram
influencer for a while now,
but I kinda know the game
of how to attract people.
The only thing I can't
really crack down is
how to start working with companies.
You know, I'll hit 'em up,
hit 'em up, hit 'em up,
and you know, they just keep ducking.
- What kind of content
are you putting out?
- Really, as you can
tell, I have curly hair,
so that's really what
catches people's attention,
so I would just leave it out,
and I would just have--
- So does that mean you're doing photos,
and call it modeling, are
you doing funny videos,
are you doing music?
What I'm trying to do,
I'm gonna give you the answer,
I just need to know what the content is.
I mean, when I hear that, I hear modeling,
which is amazing, I just want to, like,
don't worry about what you're doing,
I just want to know
exactly what you're doing
so I can give you good advice.
- Right, that's the thing, though, like,
I do everything you said.
I do modeling, I'm just
getting into music,
so my fan base is really,
like, messing with that.
I do funny videos, I
do all of it together.
- Can I give you a huge piece of advice?
- Yes.
- Take the three to four
brands that you love the most,
and what's your IG handle,
because people want it.
Veronica all ready thinks you're cute.
I see what it is.
- (laughs) It's D__rock.
- D__rock, got it.
Listen, what you need to do is
take your four favorite products.
A soap,
a candle,
a fucking drink,
a piece of gum,
your favorite candy,
your favorite deodorant,
and actually make fresh ass ads,
and then in the copy be
like, "Yo, this isn't an ad,
I'm just giving love because
I fucking love Old Spice,"
or "I fucking love Saratoga Water."
Make an ad that's fucking amazing,
whether it's a great photo, modeling,
whether it's a skit, right?
- Right.
- I'm telling you right now,
that.
- Okay, all right.
Yeah, that sounds like--
- I'm gonna break it down for you.
You know how you're, like, super cute,
and have a great smile, which
means girls come to you?
- Right.
- Other guys have to strategize to go,
you have more leverage because
you don't have to do that.
What you need to do is
that in business terms.
You need to make the commercials,
that's gonna bring them
to you, instead of you,
you're thirsty on DM, bro.
- (laughs) Oh, man.
- All those guys you made fun
of in high school and college,
and now that you see they're going,
you're like I'm just gonna
sit in the cut right here,
and it's gonna come to me?
- Right.
- You're that guy that you
made fun of with brands.
You're thirsty.
I want you to make the content as if,
and then watch the bees come to the honey.
- Okay, okay.
Got it.
One more question,
is there too much content?
- No.
- Is there any...
No, okay.
- Nope, the algorithm,
and the way humans work,
there's 'you're not good enough
to make interesting enough
content' for too much content,
but if you're good enough,
if you're funny enough,
if you're pretty enough,
if you're smart enough,
you can go forever.
- Okay.
All right, yeah, I mean,
that was really the question.
- You got it?
You got it?
- Yeah, definitely.
- Makes sense?
- I'm gonna start working on it.
- Yes.
- How many posts a day do you do?
- I do one, sometimes two.
- Great, you know where I'm going,
you've listened to me enough.
This is what's great about this,
is you need to put these four
ads out in the next two weeks,
and based on how little
you post, you're set.
You're just gonna do two a day,
four times over the next fourteen days.
You're good.
- Okay, yep, sounds perfect, man.
- All right Drock,
take care of yourself.
- Thank you so much.
- Can't wait to meet you in person.
Let's keep this going.
That was a good clip, Team GaryVee.
The whole...
Title it 'Stop Being
Thirsty for Brand Money'.
That's gonna crush on the 'Gram.
Let's go.
- Oh!
- What's up, Gary?
What's good, Kristin?
- So I'm really psyched to talk to you,
because, I don't know
if you remember this,
but I met you, like,
three years ago in Boston.
- Well, I can definitely
tell by the accent,
so I definitely know that.
- So I basically found your content,
I'm a Boston girl, so you
have a lot of the same mindset
and background as me, you know,
we both kind of come from
people, like, judging you,
little chip on the shoulder.
- Grit.
- I started seeing some of your content
because I was doing a message
of the day for my nieces,
because I used to watch them every day,
and my son had learning issues,
and to kind of, like,
put more energy into him,
and it was the teenage
years, and I didn't want him
to start loosing the--
- Self-esteem.
- Right, so I started a little
positive message of the day,
then they started adding friends,
and then it turned to like 25 teenagers.
Then, in turn, it was like
all the people in my
bar wanted to be in it,
so a lot of my customers
joined into it, so like,
45 people, 50 people for
like the past five years.
- I love that.
- I found your content, and I was like,
this dude is my dude.
He talks like me, he thinks
like me, I gotta meet this guy.
So I saw that you were gonna be in Boston,
and I got up one morning, I
just went there to wait for you,
and I met DRock.
Now listen, I'm 49, so
social media wasn't my jam,
and so DRock was like,
"Well, if you want to speak,"
"Gary's gonna tell you
you're gonna have to go out,"
"and, like, speak for
free wherever you can."
So you came up the top of the escalator,
and I looked at you,
and I said, "Hey, Gary."
"I'm Kristin, I'm a bar tender."
"I want to take my message to the masses."
"I want to come to New
York and talk to you"
"about how to build a brand."
So for three years, patience,
I've been trying to get in
front of you, and here we are.
- I love it.
- The reason I said to
the people in your team,
and your team's amazing.
- Thank you.
- I feel like I'm, like, the
poster child for your content,
because I basically
have an anecdotal story
for almost everything you say.
Basically, I though I had
super powers when I was kid.
My mom was a single mom,
so she kind of gave me, like, that armor,
that I thought that I could do anything.
- It's fucking amazing.
- Yeah, like, you know,
the inner gut, like--
- There's nothing like struggle
in real life, like, around you,
but complete and utter dominance here.
- Mindset, right.
- Mindset.
- Mental toughness.
And so, I could 'make things
happen' if I believed in it.
Like, I really though
that it could happen,
and like, I wanted
something in third grade,
so I just thought that I could really
making it always happen.
- Fucking love it.
- And my mom taught us--
- Big shout out to third grade!
- Yes, exactly!
And so, my mom taught
me, listen to my gut.
We gotta make our own choices,
and she supported your choice,
but you had to pay for the
consequences of whatever it was.
Do you know what I'm saying?
- Accounta...
Do I know what your saying?
My favorite thing on
Earth, besides kindness,
my favorite thing is accountability.
But people are confused by that,
because those feel like
very different energies.
That's why you and I connect,
because you get that.
- Exactly, so fast forward, so then,
through my life, I kind
of always had a, like,
just do what I wanted to do.
High school, I wanted to be an actress,
I was supposed to go
to a four-year school,
sat my parents down, and was
like, "It's not happening."
I'm gonna go to community college,
because if I want to
be a starving actress,
I'm not gonna be able to pay loans.
- Smart.
- So my mother was like,
she thought about it, and she's like,
"You know what, Kristen's right."
Did some different jobs,
tasted some things,
hated corporate America,
had a bad experience,
so I said, you know what, packed my shit,
moved to New York at 23.
Ate shit, like you talk about.
Sleeping on couches, rice and
beans, the whole nine yards.
And then, it was just
kind of a shady business,
and I'm just the type of person
that I don't sell my soul.
I'd rather be broke and be me,
then be rich and be somebody else.
It's just how I roll.
And so I met my husband a
few years back in Boston,
and I said, you know what,
I'm gonna give love a shot,
so I came home.
Best thing I ever did, we're
still together 21 years later.
- I love it.
- We've had a lot of experiences,
life's hit us a lot of times.
He got hurt on the job, was
out of work for two years
with an injury.
- I'm sorry.
- On a March blizzard,
our house burnt down in
the middle of the night,
and we lost everything we owned.
Got back on our feet, made a
business deal with somebody,
lost everything we owned.
So I've had to kind of
fight my way through things,
and then my son has some learning issues,
and I really had to learn
about special education which,
I could go on for days about
education in this country,
but I'm not going to,
and I fought for him day in and day out,
and after the end of getting
him where he needed to be,
I kind of was a little bit depleted.
You know what I mean, I--
- Yeah, you fucking...
You put it all...
Like sometimes you're just
put it all on the field,
and it's kind of one of those, like...
(sighs)
- Right, and I give to
everybody all the time,
and I had to learn to take
a step back for myself.
So when it was time for high school,
I decided that we were just
gonna step away from school,
in general, because I think he's creative,
and he just has a different brain.
And I said, "I just don't think
it's the right fit for him."
- Listen...
- So we're just doing
our own thing.
- If you're massively creative,
and massively entrepreneurial,
the American school system is not for you.
Let there be no fucking confusion.
- 100%.
I agree with that 100%.
- By the way, people think I hate school.
I don't hate school.
- Me neither.
- I really don't.
I hate school for certain people,
the end.
I don't hate anything.
I like self-awareness, I like self-esteem,
I like being real,
and congratulations.
Good for you.
- Thank you.
So then that kind of started the thing,
when we started home schooling,
I kind of decided to really
dive into your content,
and three of your Ask GaryVees
that really stuck out to me
were Logic, Russ, and Hasan Minhaj.
So speaking and people are my thing,
and I always wanted to figure out
how I was gonna become a speaker.
I have a lot of creative
ideas in the back of my head.
My brain moves very quickly,
and I'm kind of like a think tank.
So Hasan was like, "I
started my own comedy group
at the college," and I was like, bam!
Done, right there.
Signed myself up for an
open mic and I did comedy.
And once I got back in
front of the microphone,
and the audience again...
- You lit up.
- It just, like, reignited me.
- Lit up.
- You're energy, you basically
reignited my childhood,
and you got me back in it.
Like, you'd make a video, like,
"I don't care if your 46, I'm fucking 46!"
(laughing)
You know what I'm saying?
And I was like, I need
to talk to this guy.
So I basically started doing the comedy,
so I'm kind of hustling
home life, marriage,
bar tending at night, and
then doing the comedy thing.
I took your advice of reverse engineering,
so last year for my birthday,
I said to my husband,
"For my 48th birthday, I
want to do a one-woman show."
We rented a hall, 150
people showed up for me,
friends, families, customers
that I've waited on over the years.
I videotaped it, put it on YouTube,
kristinbeingkristin,
because that's the only
way I know how to be.
- Hold on, hold on, watch...
Hold on.
Like, first of all, I'm
super happy, and super sad.
Let me tell you why I'm super happy.
I'm super happy because I adore you,
and I can't wait to start talking, like,
this is gonna last a little bit here.
I've got stuff for you.
- Okay.
- I'm devastated because I
don't have any fans anymore,
because they all love you so
much right now, it's over.
So, put up your handle on...
How many subscribers do you
have on YouTube right now?
Dustin, get me the count,
or Kristin, you probably know.
- I don't--
- You don't know exactly?
- I think I only have, like, 60,
because I don't have
enough content on there,
but I do have some of my comedy.
- Don't worry, don't worry.
- And then my Instagram is
where I do most of my stuff,
and that's kristinbeingkristin, also.
- And how many followers do we have there?
- Like 1000, 1070.
- Okay, watch this.
- Okay.
- I'm actually gonna
watch it in real time.
This is gonna be the
most fun of my whole day,
because I promise you,
everybody here loves you more then me now,
and so it's devastating for me.
My career is over, but
yours is about to be...
- (laughs) We'll collaborate, Gary--
- Kristin, when I'm finished,
can you please hook me up?
Can you, like, at least maybe put me on
as the opening act to your
speeches, or something?
- Well, I was always like,
when you would release various speakers,
I was like, someday.
- All right.
I just followed you, so you were at 1105.
You're all ready at 1114.
- Aww, I appreciate that.
- It's moving, 1120...
No, no, put it back up, Dustin,
let's get this thing completely out of...
1137.
I want every fucking person
who's following right now,
because you know what the energy is.
If you like me, you like her.
1168.
This is YouTube and Instagram.
You're at 1200 all ready.
It's just happening.
- Unbelievable.
- 1224.
1236, Kristin, you're
life's about to change.
1253.
It's just happening now.
1271.
1290.
- Jesus Christ.
- 1308.
1323.
(Kristin laughs)
1336.
1348.
1362.
1380.
1394.
1414.
1426.
1450.
- Oh my God.
So, Gary, I've basically
been watching your show,
and I love your show, because
I miss being at the bar,
and this is kind of like
the authentic conversation
that we have nightly.
Instead of Tea With GaryVee,
I always wanted to do
Sit Down and Listen, It's
Last Call With Kristin.
- You should do..
Kristin.
You basically are siphoning
my whole fan base right now.
You should start Last Call
With Kristin as a YouTube Live.
Start it tonight, and fucking go.
- Okay.
You just go right on...
What did you say, YouTube
Live, or Facebook Live?
- Both, but you know,
my team will help you.
Team, get somebody--
- That's my thing, Gary, like technology--
- Kristin, I know!
Why do you think I'm giving you my team?
(Kristin laughs)
I got this!
This is why I interrupt everybody,
I know the fucking answers
before the questions are
coming out of people mouth.
People get mad at me and think I'm rude,
I'm not, I'm just trying to
help faster, and do more!
- Same thing.
- Yeah, like, what do you want from me?
I'm not mean, I'm not audacious,
I don't mind other people talking.
I love people talking,
I just know what the
fuck they're gonna say
before they say it.
- I feel the same.
- And I only have an hour!
I only have an hour, or
40 minutes on my podcast,
I'm trying to help
people get to more shit.
If you want to hear what
their thoughts are on that,
they're on 800,000 other podcasts.
I'm not trying to interrupt,
I'm trying to get more shit out for you.
I'm sorry that I fucking know
what people are gonna do
and say before they do it.
It's my fucking gift, I'm sorry.
- I know, it's like, when
someone talks to you,
and you see, like, a field,
because it's so easy for you,
because it's not your life.
That's how it is for me.
It's not my life, so I can say,
"You gotta do this, this, and this."
- Of corse.
- It's just like one
of those things, you do
it all in that layer.
- Of corse.
One of the things I try and
do a lot is not do that.
When I give advice I'm like,
am I taking that advice?
Because I don't want
that, "Well, fuck you."
Like, I don't want that call
back, you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- 2008.
Yeah, go ahead, I'm listening.
- One other thing, Gary,
a book has been in my head
for a very long time...
- But hold on Kristin, you
have 2100 followers now.
- Are you kidding me?
You doubled my thing in one
click within five seconds.
- We double out here, Kristin!
(Kristin laughs)
We're doubling out here.
- Well, you know--
- You know what I love
about this, Kristin?
This is why I love life.
You've been trying to get in
front of me for three years.
You never know where life goes, you know?
Like, if we would have met,
if you would have gotten an
email from DRock that said,
"15 minutes with Gary in New York,"
you would have been like, "Oh my God."
Right?
And it would have been epic,
but this is gonna change your career.
People are following you right now,
and we have similar energies.
This is gonna change your life.
- Well, I want to change
other people's lives,
so you changing me goes around
in circles, and that's what
it's all about.
- I know what's
happening here, I'm not confused.
What were you going to say, Kristin?
A book.
- A book has been in my head
for a very long time.
Originally, you're gonna
think this is crazy,
it was gonna be called "Fuck the Jones's,"
and then this summer,
when you started going,
"Fuck the Jones's,"
I was like, is this guy
in my friggin' head?
It's ridiculous.
- Well, why don't you just
call it "Fuck the McCormick's,"
and it can be very Boston.
- Well, that's true.
That's a good, good concept.
- Thank you.
- Another thing I came up with was,
"I'm Not Rich or Famous,
but I'm Happy as Fuck."
That was the other topic.
- I like that.
I kind of like "Fuck the McCormick's."
- "Fuck the McCormick's," okay.
- How about "Fuck the Kraft's?"
Or the Brady's?
(Kristin laughs)
Or the Edleman's?
(Kristin speaks inaudibly
through laughter)
Yeah, anyway...
- I figured, like, the quarantine,
because I'm not working right now,
because the bar tending is
off until everything reopens--
- Except you're gonna be
bartending every night,
live on YouTube, and Facebook, and IGTV,
and all these people
are gonna be watching.
You're at 2200, according to Matt Medlin.
- Yeah, 'cause see, the
thing is, the reason,
when it's hard for me
to talk to the camera,
it's because I love the
people, you know what I mean?
- Well, but look what--
- Right, like this.
- This.
- And so, when the quarantine happened,
I started talking to the
camera just directly,
like the way you talk about doing that,
because I was trying to help people
kind of navigate mentally through this,
because it's uncharted
territories for a lot of people,
and it kind of disrupted everybody's life,
so I'm trying to keep people positive,
and trying to keep focus.
- Kristin,
where are you with TikTok?
- Ah, I knew it.
I had it figured out, because, again,
I know that I had it figured out,
how it was gonna work for me.
I know you say just get
on there and make stuff,
and now the Story Time,
and I found Real Talk,
and some of the...
And I love to dance, like,
I'm an old school, like, hip hop, reggae--
- You're also a comedian.
- Yeah.
- Kristin, you're gonna
be a superstar on TikTok.
If you make three TikToks a day,
you're gonna be bigger then me on TikTok.
- No.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, you are.
- All right, so that's
thing, I'm just like--
- Look how...
You're like me, but you
have, like, a happy face.
I've been coming out here trying to
fucking strangle people's happiness.
You're fucking, like, you're gonna crush.
Do you understand that this is it?
Like, this is it?
- Yeah, I hope so, because I've been--
- Well, don't fucking hope!
I don't need hope!
- All right, let's fucking go!
- Kristin, in third grade you fucking...
What do you mean, 'hope'?
Go back to third grade Kristin that knows.
You fucking knew you could
will things back then.
I don't give a fuck about the burnt house,
or the fucking two year thing,
or if New York City sucks shit.
Fuck all that!
We got 50 more years to
be a fucking superstar,
that is your destiny.
Here we are today.
- Right.
Facts, 100% facts.
I agree with you.
I'm ready to do it, and the thing is,
it's all about people for me,
so it's kind of like it's not about...
It's really about just--
- Kristin, if you do not
do happy hour, or bar time,
or whatever the fuck you call it, tonight,
at 7-8:00pm, and bring people on,
and my team's gonna stay on with you.
Dustin's gonna pass you
to somebody right now.
We're gonna literally hand hold you
to build out the
infrastructure to how to do it.
- Okay, that's great.
- I'm going to get in the car,
during COVID, drive across state lines.
I don't give a fuck if Rhode
Island tries to stop me,
I'm gonna drive right
through those fuckers,
I'm gonna come to your house,
and I'm gonna burn your fucking house down
if I don't see you on tonight.
- Okay, seven to eight.
Okay, all right.
- All right.
- Okay, Gary, I appreciate you so much.
Thank you for everything.
- You got it, take care.
Good bye, Kristin.
Kristinbeingkristin, follow
her on all platforms,
especially YouTube and Instagram.
Hopefully that's her TikTok, as well.
Let's keep this going.
That was fun.
Jared!
- Hey, Gary, how's it going, man?
- Really good, bro.
I'm fucking feeling your shirt, bro.
You got me fired up.
- I saw you two years ago in Houston,
we did that Keynote with
George Bush, and all them,
and I think I caught your
attention in the front row, too,
with the same shirt.
- I remember.
I remember.
(Jared laughs)
- Good to see you, good man.
Hey, first of all,
thank you for everything you've done, man.
I truly believe you're
one of the biggest reasons
I'm even still here breathing today.
In practicing my question
for the last three days
(audio cuts out)
think I've all ready kind
of worked the answer,
knowing what you're gonna say.
What I'm kind of working with
is using patience as delusion.
Kind of like holding myself
accountable, and dwelling.
Like, I could have done more yesterday,
but I did some good, you know what I mean?
Like, accepting that,
where does gratitude become contentment?
- That's a great question.
- Where does ambition
become, like, yes, I want more,
but I'm so thankful for
what I have all ready,
in spite of nothing.
Like, everything I have
is in spite of nothing.
- Love it.
- I don't have that struggle,
and I wish I kind of did now,
but how do you find that balance?
And I think you're just
gonna look at me and say,
"It's self-awareness."
Like, I know when I'm being a lazy fuck,
and I know when I've done good.
You know what I mean?
- Yes, but I actually think
it's a little bit different then that.
Actually, it's not self-awareness for me,
maybe it is the right answer for you,
but let me go where I'm going.
You're over thinking it.
Jared, you're over--
- I overthink everything, bro.
(Jared laughs)
- No shit.
You know, you're over thinking it.
Like, do me a favor,
don't analyze tomorrow.
Excuse me, yesterday.
Stop analyzing yesterday.
- And that's the thing, like,
I don't have some arbitrary
number, you know what I mean?
Like I'm 32, I know I don't
want to be 35 delivering pizzas,
but like--
- Can I ask you a question?
On some real shit, can
I ask you a question?
- Yeah.
- Are you happy?
- Dude, I'm so happy, bro.
- Bro...
- I'm, like, the happiest I've ever been.
- Bro, listen to my fucking face.
Please, listen to my face,
because that's what caught me.
Bro, listen to my face.
Being 35 and delivering
pizza, and being happy,
is way better then being
27, and a VP on Wall Street,
and being unhappy, and
it's not fucking close.
Bro, to the last breath I breath,
I will single-handedly,
like a fucking nova,
try to change our culture
to happiness, not money.
With every ounce of my soul,
for the rest of my life,
I'm completely convinced on this.
Completely, brother.
- Yeah, and I've been following
your content for, like,
three years, dude, and it's like,
and once I started listening to you,
I was like, dude, this
is like the whole reason
I even had the confidence in myself.
Like, back then, I was
a fuck up my whole 20s.
Like, my whole 20s, but
in my head I was like,
I've got massive self-awareness,
I've got good intentions,
I'm a genuine person, like,
kindness, empathy, all that.
(audio cuts out)
But it's like, I feel like some days,
I sit back, and I'm like,
"Eh, good things happen to good people.
I'm just being a good person."
And then I'm like, "You
didn't do shit today, dude."
You need to do (audio cuts out).
I preach--
- That's right.
By the way...
- And I'm not moving fast--
(audio cuts out)
That's fine, that's different.
You know, listen, bro, you
just might not have ambition.
- (laughs) I mean, I do, but I have a
shitty work ethic.
- Stick with me here.
- Like, my work ethic is dog shit.
That's the only thing I
haven't picked up from you yet,
and I'm trying.
- Because you don't
like what you're doing.
- Yeah.
- Do you like the Jets?
- I like them because of you.
Wayne Chrebet's my dude.
(Gary laughs)
He got a raw shake,
playing in the wrong time,
and (mumbles) won a fantasy league for me
(Gary laughs)
years back
so I've got a soft spot for a few of them.
- What's your favorite shit?
Like, what do you do?
Do you like video games?
You like music?
You like fucking TV?
- So right now I'm flippin'
shit from thrift stores
on the side, and I have plans
to launch my own--
- Is that fun?
- I'm sorry?
- Do you like that?
Or do you do that because I like it?
(audio cuts out)
- Love it.
- What's up with the...
(talking over each other)
Bro, do you like the flipping?
- I love it.
Bro, you'll make a lot more
money flipping full-time,
then you will pizza.
- I just lost the audio again, man.
- You did?
No problem.
Can you hear me now, now,
now, now, now, now, now.
Can you hear me now, now, now, now, now.
- I can still here you, just so you know.
- Yeah, I know.
Can he hear me?
Can't hear me?
All right, yo, we're gonna get you back.
We're gonna get you back.
Dustin hit him up.
- I'm gonna watch.
- Let's keep going.
(sighs) It's a fun day.
- Oh.
Oh hey, Gary. (laughs)
- Hey, how are you?
What's your name, and where are you from?
- I'm from Australia, but
I live in England now,
so bit of a change.
- Nice to meet you, Adam.
- Yeah, nice to meet you too, man.
I've been following you
for, like, five years now,
but sort of behind the scenes,
never really popped on
to one of these before.
But basically, just to
give you a bit of context,
I actually followed all
of your walking advice
when I was at university,
starting my own social media agency.
Was earning, like, a
full-time wage at uni,
which is awesome, so thanks for that.
- You're welcome.
- At the end of the day, though,
I got tired of just cold calling,
and the whole service
delivery aspect of it--
- It sucks.
It's grinding.
- Yeah, so--
- Unless you love the dirt,
you can get the money,
but of you don't love
getting punched in the mouth,
services sucks.
- That's the thing, the
money was coming in,
but I was just miserable,
just working 16 hours a day,
doing that, so what I ended
up doing is making a course
to sell online, which
was showing entrepreneurs
how to grow their Instagrams,
and things like that.
That hit off, got 500 sign-ups with that.
Basically marketing that over funnels,
and what I've been doing since
is teaching my friends how to do that.
So one of my mates is a barber,
I'm teaching him how to sell courses
on how people can cut their
hair, stuff like that.
One of my mates trades Forex, so--
- Adam, make sure those
people are making courses
that are worth the money.
That world gets really
spammy, really fast,
where there's better information for free
then what their selling for $79.
Just do me a favor,
while your teaching that,
I don't begrudge anybody selling courses.
I begrudge when people
care more about the funnels
then they do about the
content in the courses,
and then the person's not
getting something good.
- Yeah, that's my question, really.
- Yeah, that's the fucking problem.
- Yeah, because at the end of the day,
I actually love teaching
people how to do this,
and I sold a course, I've
sold two of my courses so far.
And I really enjoy teaching
people, and seeing the results,
but at the same time,
my reputation's really important to me,
and I know that I'm part of this whole
'making money online thing', and it...
I don't know, I'm just--
- I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of you, I don't
know what else to say.
I'm uncomfortably proud of you.
There's a way to do it differently.
There's creating access, not just PDFs.
So now, all of a sudden,
the course could be $29,
or $800, but it also comes with one hour
of the barber's time
on FaceTime, you know?
- Yeah.
- Just something of more fucking value.
It just gets so spammy.
It gets go spammy, and people just, like,
at all costs, try to
convert on the funnel.
They put all their effort in the sales,
and none of it on the content,
and people are buying.
And then people sell hopes and dreams.
It gets real spammy
real fucking fast, bro.
All of a sudden they AB
test, and then they go,
"I'll show you how to build a barber shop
that does a million dollars," versus,
"I'm gonna show you the craft of..."
Like, it can get really bad, really fast,
and 98% of what I see
is really, really bad.
Which is why I'm putting
pressure on the game,
do the reverse, and put out
decks that are fucking fire,
for free, that then kids
like you take and repackage,
and sell.
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
Pretty much
I mean, that's sort of
what I teach in my course,
so it's not going in funnels,
but it's how to actually--
- Can I give you a very
good piece of advice?
- Yeah.
- Never pick money.
- You have a moral compass,
and you're smart enough
to believe in reputation,
because you can never get away
from who you were on the internet.
- Yeah.
- And you're young.
Leave money on the table.
- With that, obviously,
because I still want to
help people build stuff,
and I want to put out
a ton of free content--
- So do that.
Do that with zero thought
of what its gonna mean to your funnel,
because the second you
think about your funnel,
the content becomes
manipulation, not education,
because subconsciously, even
if you're a good kid like you,
you're a good kid, it's
black and white to me,
subconsciously, you're in that place.
- Yeah.
The problem is, is that I've--
- And look, Dustin Mills says,
"Information should be free."
I don't necessarily agree
with that, Dustin, completely,
like, you can sell information.
My big thing is, people
buy information everyday.
Books costs money, cable costs money,
everything can cost money.
My big thing is,
do you feel great about
what you're selling?
You know, do you like your reputation?
Does your head go on the pillow easily?
There's so many people that sell things
that put people out of business,
but they made $4000 on the course.
- Yeah.
Yeah, that makes sense.
- Adam.
Adam, you can navigate this.
You can make money by creating a course
that also comes with a virtual Keynote,
which also comes with a one-hour
session for eight weeks,
where you're giving a lot of value.
And you can change
adjectives and pictures,
because the pictures
that convert to the sale
are alluding to bullshit 99% of the time,
and you know it, and I know it.
- Yeah, literally,
because I'm running these
funnels and adverts,
and obviously I'm not doing the
rent a Lamborghini stuff like that.
That's lame, I would never do
that, and I'm never gonna...
Honestly is everything to me.
Transparency, as well.
So that's my question, really,
is how to differentiate--
- Brother, easy.
Don't compromise for money.
- Yeah.
- Bro, you're gonna make
less money after this call,
and be 30,000 times happier.
That's what I do.
Bro, I could be the richest of them all.
There's not a fucking
Lamborghini or funnel
that could beat me if I went that route.
I'm the most charismatic,
I'm the smartest,
I'm the hardest working,
I'm the fucking best,
and a lot of those fuckers
make more money then me,
because they don't give a fuck.
But guess what, they
make more money then me
in 2018, 2019,
2020,
but talk to me about '21, '22, '31,
'42,
'48.
You're a fucking kid,
don't ruin your reputation
for a couple fucking
hundred thousand bucks.
- Yeah, I mean, I want to do what you do,
and what Russ did, as well.
Build a catalog of free content,
but the problem is, I've all
ready sold these courses,
and my courses are good, like,
I work hard on these courses.
It's not, like,
a bunch of fluff.
- Make a video,
and say, "I really worked hard on these.
I felt great about them,
but I'm making a pivot."
The end.
- Yeah, but all the people
that have all ready bought the courses,
won't they be like,
"All this information's free now,
now I'm angry that I just
spent a hundred and..."
- No, because they got their
ROI, and things change.
I mean, I'm selling...
Here's a good plug, WineText time!
Adam, if you were in the
US I would make you buy,
but you got off easy.
We're about to sell a wine today
that we have sold for $32
a bottle, a chardonnay.
Everybody sells for $40 a bottle,
and we're gonna sell
it on WineText, today,
for $19.80, or something like that.
People can be happy.
By the way, things change, too, Adam.
TikTok comes out, and
they're gonna be happy
that you gave them a strategy on TikTok.
- Yeah.
- You have no problems with that.
That is a non-event.
When somebody, in eight
months, comes and says,
"I want a refund!"
You fucking do this, you're gonna say,
"No, sir, I'm sorry."
"At that point it was selling,
I've pivoted my business."
"I know you got value out
of that, I'm proud of that."
"Let's move on."
- Yeah, okay.
So just put everything out for free,
give them the roadmap,
give them everything,
and then, if they need it,
I'm here to guide them through that,
for a lot of the strategy--
- Or, give it for free
like crazy, and then also
create something called,
you know, "Access with Adam,"
where you charge people $2000 a month
to hang out with you and drink tea.
Do you know how much I could
charge for this right now?
Adam, on some real shit.
On some real shit, don't flatter me,
because we're trying to
educate and help people,
what would you pay if I
came out a week ago...
Forget about the fact that you'd be like,
"Why did Gary do this?
He's fucking changed, fuck it."
You know, forget about that.
If two weeks ago I said,
"I'm doing Tea With GaryVee
behind a closed door."
"It's two hours a day, you could be on."
"I'm doing it the whole
time, on some real shit."
Don't fluff the number,
just out of curiosity,
what do you think you would
have paid for the month of that?
You, personally?
- Well, me?
- Yeah, you.
- I've spent 6K on courses
that haven't helped me at all.
- Right, so...
Right, no, no.
On some real shit, forget
about what you've done,
what would you think you would have paid?
- Eight to 10K.
- Good.
If I put it out for $1800,
you would have been pumped,
and fucking 100,000 people
would have signed up.
- But is this, like, just
for an hour, or, like..
- No, no, I would...
Did you follow me?
Let's say two weeks ago, I made pretend,
"Hey guys, I'm doing Tea With GaryVee."
"It's a membership thing, you
gotta pay to be part of it."
"You get to watch all the content,"
you get to be in the comments."
This!
But not public and free,
closed and paid for.
Smaller group, but...
And for the whole time, for
a month, two hours a day.
Two hours a day!
- That's actually...
Yeah, that's so cool.
That gives me an idea, too.
Yeah.
- Well, I'm here to give you ideas.
I'm here to fucking help.
For free.
- Because I wanted to do that.
Originally, I wanted to just
release everything for free,
but then I'm like, how would
I, well, monetize that--
- I get it.
- And make good content.
- The bottom line it, you look at it here,
from Alisa King at $50, to
Hustle Time at 10K a month,
the bottom line is, I
probably could have made,
right now, people are scared right now.
Right now people would need me.
Put up the $50 one, you know, Dustin.
Don't throw the 10K one.
You know, but like...
You know.
Yeah, Shane goes a smaller
group, 100,000 people.
Yeah, I mean, if I went all out and sold.
There's a lot of ways to do it.
- Yeah, okay.
Yeah, that gives me food for thought.
- Bullshit ads that allude to
fake promises on the internet
to sell a product that
is just fucking content,
that if somebody took the four hours,
they could gather it on
YouTube and the internet,
it's not gonna lead to a sustained legacy,
I can promise you that.
You might make some cash up front,
but at what expense.
- That's why I started this,
because I've been the victim of it.
I bought so many courses--
- Put out content for free,
and if you need to monetize,
I do think a group, virtually,
that gets two hours of
your time once a week
for the whole year, a lot
of those people would pay.
Actually, can you see...
Oh, you can't see the comment.
On some real shit, and
it could be zero dollars.
On some real shit,
what would you pay for a
month of Tea With GaryVee,
if it was behind a closed door?
Just on some real shit, what
do you think you would pay?
From zero dollars, don't
try to act like a baller,
I'm just trying to get
some data here for you.
You know, like, people can
do it when you bring value.
So give me 1000 from Koontz, you know?
"My arm and my leg,"
thank you, that5280lady.
(Adam laughs)
You know?
There's so much,
there's so much opportunity.
$500 from (mumbles).
Like, 250 a month from somebody else.
10,000 from...
But listen, where I'm at, a
lot of people can't afford it,
but like I could easily
roll in 1000 people here
at $20,000 bucks a month.
You know how much money that is?
But that's not what I want,
I want to be happy and
I want to have legacy.
- I suppose what you're
talking about then,
that's the long game.
Like, I couldn't run paid
advertisement to my free stuff,
because my ROI--
- You could.
You could.
I have.
(Adam laughs)
Well, you just got a lesson,
and it's brand versus sales.
All these people that claim
that they're marketers,
they're fucking whore salesmen.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Using bullshit things.
Literally, a kid I met the other day,
they went to San Diego just to take photos
with cars, and girls, and animals.
- Yeah, literally.
Yeah, all right, man.
I'll do that--
- Listen to me,
you're too good of a kid.
You started going down a road,
you realized, uh-oh.
Good news, I'm fucking putting my hand it,
I'm grabbing you out.
You got this, Adam.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I'll do it.
I'll do the Russ and GaryVee method.
- I love it.
Take care, brother.
- That's sick, thanks man.
- B-bye.
People ask about how you get questions on.
Joey Miguelly, here's how.
You either hit me up at 212-931-5731,
and if you're in America or Canada,
and you're not part of my text platform,
you're making a huge mistake.
Free stuff, access, all sorts of shit.
Please take a post of
this right now on Twitter.
Share the link that
you're watching this on,
and this photo, let me just...
Let me get my tea, hold on.
Post that on Twitter, and your question,
and a hashtag, and the
URL this is on right now,
and we're gonna pick some
of you for tomorrow's show,
or the following week.
Oh, there is no show tomorrow, or Monday.
Some family stuff, so
I'll be back Tuesday.
I know that kind of hurts some feelings.
All right, let's keep this going.
Jay, what's good?
- How you doing?
- Very well.
- So first, it's an honor
to be on with you, man.
You've had a great impact on my life,
buy all your books, and
super pumped to be on.
- Thank you.
- My thing is, I was working in Higher Ed,
went to corporate that
worked with Higher Ed,
made some decent money.
It proved some concepts
that I really believed in,
in business.
Got my MBA, and I felt
like, you know what?
This stuff is...
The company I was working
for was making a difference
in student's lives, in
Higher Ed, but I felt like,
man, a lot of social justice,
non-profit organizations
could use this stuff.
I felt like non-profits and
social justice organizations
are a little behind.
They're ahead on empathy,
they're ahead on a lot of things,
but they're behind in methodology.
- I agree.
- I started helping them out,
and I had a struggle
with my business model,
and then finally, I stumbled
on doing small retainers,
or, like, $150 a month,
for a couple hours a month.
Had, like, three clients.
But then, with my wife and I,
we wanted to grow our family,
health care in the states.
I got a job at UPenn,
had a second baby,
thank God I did, because
he had some minor issues.
- I'm sorry, you chopped for a second.
You had a second child,
and you had some issues?
- Yeah, he had some
health issues at the birth.
- I'm sorry to hear that.
I'm sorry.
- And thankfully, everything's okay,
but if I didn't have the
health care, you know--
- You would have been
in big fucking trouble.
(Jay speaks inaudibly
through choppy audio)
- Yeah, so I am passionate
about a career development.
I've done the business,
I've done corporate,
I've done non-profit,
and I love helping younger
people navigate career,
and passion, and strength
building, and hustling,
and networking, and trying to, you know,
piece all that together.
But this new place I'm at wasn't
what it was all set up to
be, and so feel like I was...
I felt a little lied to.
- Hoodwinked.
Hoodwinked.
- Yeah,
I felt a little hoodwinked.
I tried to make it work.
I just don't feel like
it's a safe environment,
in terms of professionally.
I dread meetings, I dread Monday morning.
Sometimes I feel it on
Saturdays, where I dread Monday,
but I have a family, and the job I am at
has amazing health care.
- I got it.
- So I'm kind of worried
with this economy, like,
do I make the pivot and do go
back to my little small thing,
and try to build it up again,
or should I hunker down
until we see what happens?
- I think you can do the
consulting thing on the side.
I really do, and I think that you should
consider getting another job.
The job market's gonna be wild after this.
This could shape up super weird.
It's almost like a
redraft, in sports terms.
It's almost like if every
player became available,
and you redraft, like, companies
are laying off at record...
I mean, we've had more people laid off
in the last three weeks then we did
during the great recession in 2008.
I don't think people are gonna understand
what this is gonna look like.
And by the way, as a business owner
that's fighting every hour, right now,
to save every job he can,
it's gonna get worse.
But then I think it's gonna happen
that it's gonna come back
pretty quickly, I really do.
Like, at worse case scenario,
a year from now when the
fucking vaccine comes,
people be poppin', you know?
So Jay, for me, if you were my brother,
and that's how I treat
every one of these calls,
brother and sister, my
quick hot take intuition is,
you start the side consulting business.
If you're talking about
a couple hours a week,
you know, at $150,
A, I would try to push that up,
though they might be struggling right now,
because donations are...
You know?
But even let's say that,
because, you know, $450, like, cool...
$150 a month for a couple hours
a week, is that what it was?
- No, a couple hours a month
for 150.
- Oh, beautiful.
Nice.
I think you could go back
out with that product,
you fucking work at night, you know?
I promise you, when you
hate your fucking job,
and you come home, and you have
to work on this other thing,
it actually makes you happier.
That two hours of work makes you happier.
You may want to see the two kids,
you may want to see your lovely wife,
but it's still gonna make you happier.
When the kids are asleep, and, like..
And guess what, we all
have to eat shit sometimes.
Sometimes there's a war,
sometimes there's a pandemic,
sometimes there's a massive economy.
My take is you start
the side business now.
It may be tricky, you may not
be able to get people back.
You keep that, and then when
things go into the redraft,
right, like September, October, January,
when it starts picking back,
I think you get another job,
a different job doing something similar.
You might make a little less money,
because I think the salary's gonna reset,
but you'll be happy as fuck,
which will give you energy
to build up your 150.
You get nine of those,
you see where I'm going?
- Yeah, yeah.
Another question, too,
we have some savings, some (mumbles),
the taxing that this guy's doing--
- Well, what's happening
right now with the job?
Are you furloughed?
Or are you sitting at home?
Or, what's happening.
- No, I'm working remotely.
- Dude, you fucking won the lottery.
- That's true, that's true,
and that's where it goes back to, like,
the happiness versus
dread, versus gratefulness.
- You have to happier now
that you're not actually
physically around the negativity, right?
You still have it mentally,
but you're at least physically not there.
Or are you more unhappy,
or are you happier?
- I'm equally unhappy.
(Gary laughs)
The unhealthy dynamics
translate virtually.
- Of corse.
When somebody's a shit hole,
they're a shit hole
virtually and in real life.
Jay, listen, I think that
the leadership of a family
has responsibilities.
I think taking high risk moves
of tapping into savings
right now is extremely risky.
I also don't want you to
break down emotionally
from deep sadness.
- Yeah, I was using just the savings
from getting certifications on...
I'm a tech nerd, I love
Linux, I love open source,
I love that whole tech world.
Unfortunately, I was so in the sunken cost
of my other educational pathways,
that I could never break
away, make a pivot.
I didn't know if I should
get a certificate--
- Bro, no, fuck, no,
you're too schooled out.
Companies hire people that
don't have any fucking educa...
Fuck a certificate.
Fucking just email people, like,
if you can fucking code,
you can fucking code.
Development is like fucking sports.
LeBron doesn't have a fucking
degree from a college.
- Yeah.
- You're in that framework, right?
Ivy League school where you work at.
I'm listening to you.
Fuck that framework.
Just literally email
1000 people on LinkedIn,
and say, "I can fucking code."
"Where'd you go to school?"
"Not for that, but here's where I went..."
"But I can do it!"
You'd be very surprised
how much entrepreneurship
has seeped into corporate America.
All you need is one CTO to be like,
"Yeah, this guy can code.
Hired."
Don't fucking get your validation
from a piece of paper
that costs a ton of money.
- Yeah, well, I still have
to learn the process, though,
because I don't know how to code yet.
- Got it, got it.
Respect.
There's a lot of fucking free fucking ways
to learn it on the internet.
- Yeah, okay.
- That's what I would do.
- So I grind it out with my
job, learn something at night.
- Listen, eating shit
for as long as possible
is always the right strategy,
but you have to stop eating shit
when you know you're on
the verge of breaking,
and only you can decide that.
But unfortunately,
a lot of us men and women out
here have responsibilities,
that our decisions have
ramification on others, you know?
I have a lot of family
involved in my decisions,
and then I have 1000 lives,
and those people are family to me, too.
- Yeah, my wife has a decent income.
Her benefits package,
will be, eh, it's okay,
which will allow me some flexibility.
- Well, that's huge, and then
if you look at everything,
you know, maybe you don't
need Netflix for a year,
maybe you don't need to
use the amazing Dove soap,
and use fucking, you know, store soap.
When I hear that, adds another element.
Now it becomes a function
of your expenses to live.
If you're gonna put that burden, you know,
because your wife's
gonna feel that burden,
now you want to look at everything,
like, look at every expense.
- Yeah, okay, so I got some options
to go through.
- You got a lot of options.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Free internet learning,
cutting expenses on dumb shit,
eating shit,
you got nothing but fucking options,
even when for a lot of people,
at the beginning of this,
seemed like you had no options.
You always got fucking options, people.
- Yeah, yeah, and sorry
about that unhappiness,
the toxics thing.
- You definitely got to get out of there.
You gotta get out of there.
I don't mind, you know, six more...
Listen, I'm like in third grade,
I'm like, "I gotta get
the fuck out of here!"
And I had to eat shit.
I was unhappy for nine years
on some real shit, brother.
You think I'm mad at schools
for entrepreneurs and creatives,
because it's an ideology,
or I think it's funny, or I like razzing?
I hate negativity.
I'm doing it because it leads
to deep unhappiness for children.
- Yes.
- I was deeply unhappy,
I'm like, "Oh fuck, I
gotta get out of here!
Wait a minute, nine more years?"
You know, nine more months for you,
as a grown up, feels super easy for a kid
that went through nine more
years, and he really meant it.
I'm not trying to act cool, now.
It was deep unhappiness at
being in that school system.
I had nice teachers, it was
just a fucking shitty world.
You want me to memorize
shit that means nothing?
- Yeah, and then with the piece with--
- Real quick, Jay, I apologize.
Parents, please, if you
have a creative kid,
or an entrepreneurial kid,
I'm not saying let them
drop out of high school,
I'm not saying let them be a dick face,
but I'm saying maybe take a little
of the gas off the pedal of some ideology,
because you wish you
went to a good college,
or your mom's big on education,
like, love your child.
Deploy self-awareness and empathy.
- Yeah, that was a big
piece of that fire, too,
when I first started
the side business thing,
when I took it full-time was,
I was like, people, they
have all this information
on the table now, taking a
look at it, I want to almost
evangelize that information...
- I love that.
I love that.
- And take it to the masses,
and I was all fired up,
we're gonna do this, and then, you know,
life punches you.
- Life, life.
- And then the safety nets, oh my God--
- And Jay, it is about gratitude, right?
A child has some
complications, scary as fuck,
you know the next day, somebody's
child was stillbirthed,
or their spouse died in a car accident.
Life is life, bro.
My mom, I lost her at five.
My mom's the greatest mom in the world,
executed by a woman that
didn't have a mother.
Life.
- Yeah.
- Life, man.
I gotta bounce.
Thank you, Jay.
- Thank you.
Good luck.
Making some differences
out here today, man.
Tea With GaryVee.
I'm seeing you guys on social.
I'm seeing you on social.
By the way, anyone who signs
up for WineText right now,
please leave a comment
so I can give you a shout
out that you just did.
Fuckin...
I see your comments out there.
People really feeling this format.
"Tea With GaryVee,
better then any education
during quarantine."
Thank you.
(mumbles)
Fuck, let's keep it going.
Thanks, channel.
Oh, Roberto!
What's good, bro?
- Hey, what's up?
Can you hear me, Gary?
- Oh, clearer then anybody else,
you got a fucking whole system in there.
You look like you're a fucking
movie star, motherfucker.
How are you?
- I'm doing good, man.
I'm hanging in there, with
everything that's going on.
- Talk to me.
- It's been literally
almost six years to the day,
since Ask GaryVee episode 38,
where you answered that question,
"What's the biggest barrier to success,
a lack of capital, or a lack of time?"
And I think you remember
what your answer was.
- You know what's funny?
I honestly don't know, Roberto,
but you're gonna remind me.
It's funny how we evolve over time.
One more time, what's the
biggest barrier to success,
or what was it?
- It was, "What's the
biggest barrier to success,
a lack of time, or a lack of capital?"
- You know, listen, I
value time over capital
by a trillion miles, but
it's a lack of self-esteem.
- (snaps) You know what
you said six years ago?
You said it was a lack of optimism,
which is tied directly
to that self-esteem.
- I love it.
I love how consistent I am.
Fucking love it.
- Exactly.
But with that in mind, right now,
like, with everything that's going on
in the world right now,
not just with corona,
but also just like...
Corona has done something
that you talk about a lot,
is that these things don't change us,
they expose us, right?
- Yes.
- This has exposed, for a lot of people,
the vulnerability of their situation.
Not just with the
priority of their health,
but with what their financial future is,
their career, all these things,
all these frameworks
that they've invested in.
Like, the veil's been pulled back.
The floor has been ripped
out from under people,
which is horrible, which is devastating,
but it's effected people's self-esteem,
and it's also effecting
even people like me,
who aren't necessarily
directly negatively impacted.
Like, things are going
well for me, thankfully,
but, like, I'm watching
other people go through,
and it's hard, even for
me, to maintain optimism
in the face of their pain,
and then for them, I know
that their entire self-esteem
has been wrapped up in
the identity of their job,
of their career, of
their earning potential.
Their certainty and future,
their ability to be optimistic
has been predicated on this
security that was an illusion.
- Because people value
money too much, bro.
- Yeah, facts.
- Facts.
Like, you know, you've
watched me for a long time.
We know each other.
I keep going deeper,
and I'm like, oh, shit,
I'm gonna single handedly
fucking reframe fucking success.
That dude that we had
earlier, hope he comes back,
maybe tomorrow, or maybe Tuesday,
because it sucks that I'm
not on Friday to Monday.
I'm gonna miss it too.
We need to reframe success, bro.
That dude is happy.
He's fucking delivering pizzas
at 32, and he's clearly...
That's why I asked him,
you know, I'm vibing.
You know how I roll, I'm like,
"Wait a minute, are you happy?"
And he's like, "Yeah," and I'm
like, "Bro, you fucking won."
- That's it.
- Could you imagine if this created
people wrapping their self-esteem
in the fact that they're kind people,
and they're happy, not
that they make 180 a year,
and have a Bimmer?
- Exactly so, you're a 1000% right.
Like, the thing that has
made me the happiness,
is that I'm in a position
to where it's like,
my younger siblings and my parents
don't have to worry
about anything right now.
- That's awesome,
congratulations.
- Like with this chaos
in the world...
- That's huge.
- I've been able to protect...
Like, that's the thing that
means the most to me, Gary,
is that I'm able to protect people.
(blows air threw lips)
- Like, brother, I love you,
like, it's all I know.
I'm a fucking leader.
Put it on me.
- Exactly.
Even since I was a little kid, right,
I always kind of wanted
to step up, and do that,
and help my mom after the
divorce, and all these things,
but it's like, I never had any,
quote/unquote real power.
And then, even when I was working,
I was never making enough,
but then when I became an entrepreneur,
I could take control over everything,
because I could take
responsibility for everything.
That's a situation I was able to create
over a period of time.
What is something more?
How do we help more people?
How do people that are in
the position you or I am in
right now, help people
to shift this framework,
because right now I know the obsession is
they see the writing on the wall,
but right now what they're
staring down the barrel of
is survival, and uncertainty.
- Two ways to help:
speaking truth, and financially helping.
Black and white, and gray.
Literally, three weeks
ago, I'm like, uh-oh.
First things I did was hit up Lou and Sid,
and said, "We're buying masks
at a premium price right now,
because by the time all
this shit comes from China,
these next three weeks are gonna suck,
so I know I can buy them for 80 cents,
but let's buy tens of
thousands at four bucks,
and we're gonna donate them to New Jersey
and New York hospitals.
The second thing I did, was
start a Tea With GaryVee.
- Yeah, no, 1000%, like this is--
- And by the way, not everyone can afford
to do what I did on the personal side,
but everybody can do
what I'm doing right now.
- Right.
So something I've been
trying to do with my content,
is I've been trying to gear more people up
toward freelancing,
because the world hasn't
completely shut down,
because there's still
land grabs right now,
in terms of cash and
carry, and the thing is--
- Oh, there's real opportunity.
There's real...
Oh, Roberto, all this...
Listen, brother, this is just exposing,
like I've always said.
Like you brought up
all ready in this call,
winners are winning more.
- Truth.
Like, truth.
I mean--
- Like, VaynerMedia's on the attack.
Like, I'm on the attack.
I've got my 15 top executives with me,
all on Zoom, all in our LinkedIns,
reaching out to anybody we've ever
fucking crossed paths with,
because we're a fucking offense out here.
I'm not dwelling about
which customer can't pay me,
or fucking is gonna fire us
because they can't
afford anything anymore.
I'm going after everybody
else's fucking meat.
- Yeah, facts.
- I'm gonna eat,
because I'm a fucking AAA.
- What do you think for people
that haven't quite gotten there yet?
Like for the people who
watch us, right now,
what do you think is, like,
the most important thing somebody can do
over the next 30 days?
- Roberto, you know,
because you used to watch me,
and then you started doing it.
- You're right.
- It's called 'action'.
- Got you.
- It's fucking work ethic.
Like, you know what's so crazy?
You know, I'm heralded in 2008, '9. '10
for "Crush It!," "Hustle,"
because people were hurting,
and they needed some
good energy to work hard.
Then things got good,
and the last few years,
I'm getting shit on for "Hustle."
"You're burning people out, Gary," right?
You saw it, you're always in the trenches,
I know you're watching.
Guess what is about to
become really cool next year?
Hustle.
- I get it, I hear you.
- Whether you want to call it 'hustle',
that's a bad word now, fine,
let's call it 'hard work'.
- Right.
No, I've seen the coding,
I've seen people with the language,
I've seen the coded
language play of people.
It's like, okay, we're going
to demonize these words,
and everything like that,
with no context to how to use these words.
- That's right, and it's fine.
Listen, I know I've gotten bigger.
I know how rap works, right?
You try to battle the person
that's bigger then you.
I understand it all, it
doesn't even bother me.
I have a very funny
feeling that work ethic
is about to be put on a pedestal again.
When, 10 years in, everyone's
spending all their time
talking about work-life
balance, and they should.
Mental happi...
I'm the number one fan.
I just told somebody
who delivers pizza that,
"You're the best."
I'm not about that money,
I'm about happiness.
However, you know, work
ethic's part of it.
- It is, in the sense that it's the thing,
like you've constantly said,
that people can control.
And you can't control, right now,
what happened in the economy,
and all these things,
and everything like that.
What you can control is the
opportunity to scale up.
You can control the
opportunity to reach out.
opportunity to offer value.
- Roberto, let me make
this very clear for you,
and everybody who's watching,
and I think you know this.
What is about to happen is
triple As, because somebody
asked, "What does that mean?"
winners, are about to super shine,
fake winners are about
to burn to the ground.
All those Instagram fucking entrepreneurs
that were spending all their money
to make pretend they were successful,
instead of spending time
making themselves successful,
they're gonna get annihilated.
People are gonna have
self-awareness moments,
where they're gonna realize their steeze
was a little bit bigger.
They're gonna realize where they sit.
It's a reset, and the most insecure,
and the people with the
least mental foundation
are gonna dwell, and blame.
- 1000%.
You're 1000% right, and you
know what's interesting?
You said it, and it makes total sense,
is that right now, because
when we're under threat,
when things are happening,
you know what comes up?
Our insecurities comes out, you know,
that's the revealing thing,
of whatever we're insecure about--
- And we start admiring different things.
That boss that was a little gruff,
but fucking held shit down,
who was, like, not nice.
All of a sudden, she's holding shit down,
and saving your job, you're like,
"Wait a minute, I like Karen."
"Yeah, she can be a little
rough once and a while,"
"but I've got my job now,"
"because she fucking
sold another account."
We start admiring different
things when things get scary.
- Exactly so.
You know what, there are
people who are wartime leaders,
and there are people who
are peacetime leaders.
And we've had a long period,
we've had this bull market, to
where people have been very,
I think even with some of the stuff
with people coming after you,
is because you might be
a better wartime leader
then a peacetime leader.
And you know, it's easy
to criticize somebody--
- Brother, I'm a great fucking...
And guess what, I'm a great
fucking peacetime leader.
What happened with me,
is I was getting so big
that the people were looking
for ways to build themselves up
on fucking non-contextualizing
what the fuck I say,
and that's fucking facts.
- Mm-hmm.
No, I've seen it, I've seen it.
I've read the headlines.
- Yeah, and listen, and by the way,
I've got the fucking bravado,
but honestly, no animosity.
Like, I get it, it's all what It is.
The truth always wins in the end.
I don't care if the crowd's booing me,
I don't care if my hometown...
Man, I would be such a
great fucking athlete.
I would be so motivated if the other team
went on a 12-0 run, and the
whole garden was booing on us.
I'd be like, "Okay, I
understand you, fan,"
"and now I'm about to fucking
drop dirty in this quarter,"
"to make you fucking
cheer my fucking name."
- Well, that's why Rocky
III is your favorite Rocky.
It's because, with Ivan
Drago, like, everyone's booing
Rocky Bal--
- Four, four, four, four.
- Oh, no, sorry.
It's four, you're right.
- Yeah, go ahead.
- Why'd I superimpose that?
- It's all right,
it's all right.
- But Rocky IV, where he's in Russia
and everybody's booing him.
By the end, he has half the crowd.
He's won them over purely
on grit, and on work ethic--
- On the results.
On the fucking results.
Bro, I know how this story ends.
And honestly, because I know
100% how this story ends,
I want everybody else
to have a story, too.
Because I got love.
- What I want, and what
I think you want, too,
is I want people to start realizing
this is the opportunity
to write your own story,
because I think that people,
from their insecurity,
are being reactive right now.
I think even criticism of other people
is just being reactive
about your own insecurity...
- 100%, 100%.
Superimposing on to someone
else to demonize, instead of
just doing the harder thing,
which is keeping your
mouth shut, and saying,
"You know what, I'm going to focus on me,"
"and I'm going to focus on why is it"
"I am upset with that person."
I'm not upset with what they
did, I'm upset with how I feel,
and I'm projecting something onto them,
and so if you address that--
- Roberto, it's not fun
to be held accountable.
It's much more fun to blame
your alcoholic mother.
It's so much more fun to blame
the city you were born in.
It's so much more fun--
- To blame the government,
to blame, yeah...
- Everything.
By the way, that doesn't mean
that those things aren't true.
- Correct.
- That's not a separate thing.
To my dearest friends,
like, the people I care about the most,
that go into dwell city...
You know a little bit of my story.
College, 90% of my friends
were African American,
dealing with so many
different issues then I was.
Like, in those deep, 4:00am,
drinking a fucking 40 of OE,
when you're now family, and
you can go there, it's like,
"Yo, I get it, bro, but
nobody's gonna cry for you,"
"because they're crying about themselves."
"Like, you can spend
the rest of your life"
"dwelling that your dad left,"
"and that you get pulled over by the cops"
"more then I do, and it's
all true, and you're right,"
comma, "What the fuck,"
and this is when you can be a real friend,
"What are we gonna do about it?"
- Exactly.
And you know, the hard
thing to accept to that
is that it's more likely,
and more practical,
that you change then the environment
and circumstances change,
or they'll only get better--
- Racism?
Racism?
Racism is not gonna get better in America,
to the ideal place we all want it,
before you die.
- There are periods of
time where it gets worse,
you know, like right now.
- Anti-Semitism, exploding.
I've got more anti-Semitism
in the last fucking
three years, four years, five years,
then I did in my whole life.
- Yeah, I don't doubt it.
- By the way, and then
real stuff happened.
How about the nice gentleman right before?
You could be worried about
all these macro-issues,
and then your child can have a...
Like, life.
- And then that becomes
irrelevant very quickly.
- What about the fact that I could
get hit by a bus and die?
Like, it's life.
You're not in control of so much shit.
Everyone spends so much time dwelling
about what they're not in control of,
this fantasy that you can control shit.
Focus on what you can control.
Get yourself fucking happy.
- So what happened for me was, like,
and again, I grew up Catholic (mumbles)
so I grew up Catholic,
and what happened for me is when, like--
- Put Swami back up.
Put Swami back up.
I see it every fucking day that
I'm in the fucking airport.
Fuck that shit.
And before that, nothing,
and then 9/11 happens, and guess what...
I'm sorry, Roberto.
- When I was growing my hair,
I constantly got pat down
because of my dreads and stuff.
Bro, bro!
When I got my tan, right?
And went serious on this shit!
Come on!
- Yeah, it happens all the time...
The thing that I learned is,
is like, I realize--
- What about the reverse game?
I'm watching my white friends crying,
because people are
deploying privilege on them,
and this fucker grew up
in a fucking trailer home.
People don't know him.
Nobody knows anybody.
All they want to do is fucking judge.
Mind your own fucking
business, worry about yourself.
Stop telling other people
how to fix themselves,
fix you!
- Here's what I can control,
and here's what I can't.
Now the things that I
can't necessarily control,
the thing is, if I work on myself,
then am I later in a position
to have an impact on that?
So if you care about a macro-issue,
the best thing that you could probably do
is become powerful enough
to address that macro-issue.
You do that by doing
the micro on yourself.
- Roberto, that's exactly what I'm doing.
I want to change what
young men think of success,
specifically, and
obviously young women, too,
but I know what my demo...
I know what's happening out there.
I think it's...
When we look at our numbers,
it's 65-35, but, but, but, but
young men, who are impressionable,
and who want that lifestyle,
I can fucking break them down.
I've become an alpha to them, and now...
Do you know what it feels
like to me, Roberto?
And you're in the culture
of tech and social,
so I know you've seen my impact.
22-year-olds saying 'Gratitude?"
I'm changing the fucking lexicon.
- You have, you changed the
language, the code, the lexicon.
You have, you've had an impact.
It's not bravado to say that, it's truth.
It's true, and I've seen
the relevancy change,
and not just because your numbers change,
but I was there where you
had 28,000 subscribers.
I was there when it's like, "Gary who?"
Like, I remember when I
couldn't pronounce your name.
Like, I remember.
- I know you do.
- It wasn't that long ago.
- Nope.
- But in that short
period of time, the
impact that you've had,
and the scale that you've had
because you've reached
outside of even the micro
of only business and
entrepreneurial people,
and social media people
used to watch you, and now--
- Dustin, put Kim Jacobs' post in here.
Keep going, Roberto, I'm sorry,
but I wanted her to get this...
There we go.
- And now you're macro...
- Yes!
- Been getting macro-relevance
to the average person.
There are people who are not entrepreneurs
who know who Gary Vaynerchuk
is now, and that's a big deal.
- Roberto, every single
fucking person on earth
is gonna know who the fuck I am,
and I'm gonna take that power,
and I'm gonna do the goodest good good
of fucking all time with it.
- Yeah, I believe it.
I'm seeing it, I've watched.
There are people who say things like that,
and then there are people who do it,
and I've been watching, and you know...
And that's why so many
of us that have our own,
you know, micro version of success,
all still look up to you, still watch,
even though we quote/unquote made it
in the eyes of other people.
- And it's why I still
put you on shit like this,
because I want you to
go to the next place,
and the next place, and the next person,
and the next place.
Man, it's all fucking... (claps)
It's all fucking going to happen.
- Yeah.
- And times like this,
weed some shit out,
because there was some
real fucking confusion
of who the As and who
the Fs were out there,
and you got caught in
fucking pictures and videos,
but shit's gonna get real clean.
- Yeah, I've seen it, it's like, you know?
- It's about to get so clean.
- I'm so happy that people's priorities,
like, this is a bad thing that happened,
but you have to take the circumstances--
- Yeah, look...
Look, this is devastating,
people are dying,
but people are dying everyday
about all sorts of things.
- But now, more of us are gonna
come together for one thing.
- I believe that.
- More people are going to
shift their priorities.
Like, look at what Jack just did,
with what he just did,
and how he stepped up,
and everything like that.
- It's amazing.
- For all the crap he gets,
look at Bezos.
Bezos went in 100 million,
on that 10 million on climate change.
- Listen, Roberto, people have
made decisions about people
without looking under the hood.
Do you know how many people's spouses
or best friends hate me, and
think I'm a snake oil salesman,
and full of myself, and a piece of shit,
but they've never spend
10 hours educating?
- Right, you're a snake oil
salesman, selling false hope,
when all you do is tell
people to work harder,
and you give it away for free.
(laughing)
- But what's amazing is, literally,
right now in the
comments, everyone's like,
me, me, my sister, my
brother, my wife, my husband.
Everyone's like, "He's
a motivational speaker."
"You mean the one that's constantly"
"built businesses his whole life,"
"every minute that he's been a grown up,"
"and they've exploded, and been
the biggest in their craft?"
"That guy?"
- Yeah, like, literally, it's like--
- That's cool.
That's cool.
- How much of that is--
- What are they gonna say
when I hold up a Super Bowl trophy
as the New York Jets owner.
What are they gonna say there?
I got lucky?
- Yeah, people don't even
realize something like this.
Something people haven't
reverse engineered,
and you've said it, is you
know that you have to make
billions in order to buy
the New York Jets, right?
So then, all of your actions
are mapped to the vision
that you have of the intention
of being able to execute on that,
because there's a whole pathway
of everything you have to do.
Do you realize how much value...
You know this, but the people
in the audience don't realize this.
People think that being
a billionaire is luck,
or scummy, or you step
on people to do that,
and everything like that.
The only real way, aside
from inheriting money,
and leaving it to get
compound interest, would be,
you'd have to serve millions of people
at a high enough level of value,
in order to generate billions of dollars,
because everything, at least
in the world of capitalism,
is transactional.
- 100%
- It's impossible to actually
scam your way to billions.
- And for me, what's
really funny about it, is
the effort behind it,
in a good way.
That's why the Honey Empire.
I'll probably write
that book, about Vayner,
like, we're doing it in such
a good way, and we're winning.
You know, this was always
my problem with Steve Jobs.
That reputation that you have to be a dick
to be Steve Jobs lead to...
I watched my friends!
As Steve's career exploded,
I watched my friends in
Silicon Valley become dicks,
and that's what probably
etched in my brain, Roberto,
of me going ham on who I actually am.
You know, Roberto, what you
had the luxury of knowing,
that has become a little more
obvious in the last two years
because of how my content's unfolded,
or the last four years
with Drock, and blogging,
you can get a little bit
deeper, you can see nuances.
You kind of all ready knew
that I was a nice person.
- Yes.
- I'm an aggressive communicator,
which makes all the
people that are in here,
like my girlfriend, my brother, all that.
I get it, I understand, I'm empathetic--
- I grew up around military
dudes, so I could parse that--
- Yeah, it was easy for you,
but you also knew the
truth of my humanity.
- Yes.
- And I kind of held that
back, the same way...
It was actually uncomfortable for me
to say about the mask things earlier.
I was like, "Ooh, why'd I say that?"
Like, I don't talk about
my non-profit world.
I under-promote Pencils
of Promise, and charity.
- I don't talk about any of
the philanthropic things I do.
I don't publicly Tweet out my donations
to this thing or that thing,
with the exception of Team Trees,
because I wanted more people to do it,
and so I'm reconsidering
that as an inspiration.
- I think it's important that people know
that you can be a millionaire,
and I hate that term,
but it's exactly what I'm gonna say,
that you can be a millionaire
doing it the right way,
and being kind.
And I think that we got
to a place in culture
where people didn't believe that,
and I want to put that on my...
And then, comma, because
that's for one group,
I want everybody to know
that $36,000 a year, happy,
is winning in life.
- It is, like, how much do
you think some of the people
not believing things is
style over substance,
meaning there are people who either,
like the Steve Jobs being a dick thing,
stylistically, though, he, to
the masses, seemed one way,
but then, in the micro-relationships,
it's known that he was another way.
And so it looked good to be Steve Jobs,
but then, the style of
how you communicate--
- I call it Christopher Columbus.
- We loved Christopher
Columbus in this world,
until about 20 years ago.
- Right.
- You know, I'd rather be
respected long after I'm gone,
then right now.
- I think it matters, like, it really--
- It matters to me,
and I very much pick up on the
argument from other people,
and be like, what the fuck
are you talking about?
Like, I want to be happy now.
And I'm like, I understand,
what makes me happy is building
a legacy that is admired,
the end.
- Well, doing everything again.
You're intentional, you're
doing things, again,
for thinking about the funeral,
and thinking after how your gone,
and thinking about how
people talk about you,
because again, Steve Jobs
kind of got it at the end,
and had regrets about, like, the context--
- I don't want to be that guy.
I don't want to be that guy.
I don't want to invent this.
I admire him tremendously,
I'm not shitting on someone who's passed.
I just don't want to be that guy.
- Yeah, I think that people have a problem
reconciling their ambition,
versus their attitude,
because how you play the game matters.
And the thing is, we're
aggressively in a culture,
and taught in a culture, but
I think that's from scarcity.
I think from scarcity,
people have a zero sum game mentality,
a win it all mentality.
- 100%.
- I think that's why people
even demonize successful people,
and they demonize them because they think
that you could only have
won, if it was at my expense,
or the expense of someone like me.
- Roberto.
Roberto.
I've built 5000 agencies,
because I've put out so
much free content and decks,
people have built
agencies on repackaging--
- I know people who've done it.
- I know tons of people who've done it.
(Roberto laughs)
I believe in abundance, I believe in love.
- Yeah, I think on a long enough--
- I gotta go, Roberto.
I got a fucking important client call.
- Oh, absolutely.
- This was too much fun.
I love you, this was a lot of fun.
- Yeah, absolutely, man.
- I appreciate you.
I'll talk to you soon.
- Thanks so much
for having me, man.
Talk to you soon.
- Happy to have you, Roberto.
Dustin, thank you for being
on the one's and twos.
- Yes, sir.
- These episodes, huh?
Saw somebody say this
was like a mini podcast.
We're like doin' it, like, we're doin' it,
doin' it, doin' it well.
- Yeah.
It's cool.
Do you know what that reference was?
- No. (laughs)
- Read the comments.
"Doin' it, doin' it, doin' it well."
You young fuckers.
Some OGs, tell him what it is,
There it is, that LL Cool J.
- Oh, yeah, I only know
"Mama Said Knock You Out."
- Which is way older.
(Dustin laughs)
Anyway, I appreciate it, everybody.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Please take a screenshot
of this, right now.
Please sign up for WineText,
we go out in an hour.
An uncanny chardonnay for under $20,
this is my one commercial
during teatime, for my pops.
I would never forget.
For my pops.
It would mean the world to me,
and I mean the actual world to me,
that if you buy wine on the internet,
of if you buy wine, that you
sign up for WineText.com.
The best deals you'll ever see.
I work on them every day
with my best friend Brandon.
And Empathy Wines, the winery I started.
It's really fun to be back to my roots.
Sports cards, and wine.
But WineText is bonkers.
One deal a day.
Today's a super famous chardonnay, like,
the kind that you see on the
restaurant list for $100,
for $19 and change.
You should buy a case,
and drink it all summer.
See ya!
- Okay, so Team Gary has made a lot
of content over the years,
but what's your favorite piece of content?
- That's a great question.
My favorite content, by far, is...
I'm considering doing a
VaynerMedia operations
stay at home day once a week, forever,
because I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day,
then sometimes in a month.